Celine was asking what's the best way to
get one-on-one clients so honestly the
best way is to referrals as much as I'm
like a Content guy and I love making
videos and content but the best way is
through referrals like do a kick-ass job
with the people who you are doing work
with so that one they want to hire you
back depending on what you're selling
until they introduce you to other people
but like this person is so good that
they want to tell their friends about
you most people won't give a bad service
if you ask them how good was my service
they'll probably say oh yeah yeah you
did great but is it so good that they
want to then like you're forcing them or
guilting them to tell their friends
about you and a lot of times that comes
from helping them Beyond just the thing
that you're helping them with like
they're coming to you for a reason cool
but the concept would be their chief
goal officer like what are they actually
trying to accomplish and go help them
accomplish that I just came back from
Vegas and I was speaking an event and
pretty much every speaker flies in and
flies out and that's their thing right
off to the next thing my favorite thing
is to hang out in the hallway afterwards
so I speak on stage and then speak so
much in the hallway that Zane has to
pull me aside and say sorry guys last
question he has to go to bed which is
usually Nina's job but she wasn't there
so Zayn became my Nina for the Chip And
by the way zanina was very grateful that
you uh stepped in and uh helped with
that because I I'll get sick because
I'll spend so much time helping people
in the hallway
um but if you think about like what's
the goal of
what am I being paid to do like to come
and speak cool but then I'm gonna stick
around in the hallway and help everybody
afterwards because that's helping the
client even so much more
right and then you get hired to come
back and then you get if they're
thinking about who are they going to
recommend to other people to speak
they're gonna they're gonna often pick
me because the extra work that you're
putting in so it's not that you're not
doing a good enough job like well but
they got a result cool but did you help
them so much that they feel like almost
guilted into trying other ways to help
you out
and so referrals is the number one way
to grow a one-on-one client business if
you're a service-based business the the
fastest way to grow it is through
referrals
now that doesn't necessarily scale
right that's not how you build a you
know 10 million dollar company
but it's the fastest way to get going
and get started if we're going to use
content so if you look at build to serve
we tend to always focus on the thought
leadership and the content but there's
three strategies at the back of the book
on how to win right there's the fast
passive Freedom there's Partnerships and
then there's thought leadership and
Partnerships is basically what we just
talked about it's like referral
strategies uh for the content
that the best way to do it is to do the
thing that you're doing live on inside
your content so Zane wants a
self-confidence coaching he should be
doing confidence coaching as part of his
content calendar we had somebody in
brand Linux this morning uh who was
doing she helps actors
uh get get into Hollywood you know and
all the tips and so one of the video
ideas we came up with was her doing
critiques of people's audition reels so
to get into a film you have to do an
audition reel and send it in they never
get feedback on whether it was good or
bad they just know if they got the pot
or not so have them send the audition
real to her
and she'll put a make a video on it
breaking it down and critiquing it and
saying all the points where where where
it's falling apart like here's why it
didn't get hired I think we were going
to call it like why you didn't get the
role or something and she basically
breaks down and tells you why you didn't
get hired for the job what's wrong with
it
if she wants to sell those services
it's much easier to get clients with
that kind of content than with here are
five ways to win in Hollywood
because the fact that you can speak
doesn't mean you're gonna be a great
coach
so what are you trying to sell and then
show me you doing it
right but the easiest way would be
referrals so I don't know what you're
selling
um salima we're trying to get clients
towards but go in even for free so Drew
and Jeremy are two people who I both
invested into and train the YouTube side
of things and they both have mid six
figure businesses now Jeremy would start
a little sooner Jeremy went from being a
stock boy at a grocery store making
minimum wage to then now having a mid
six figure business and he's like I
don't know if I want to work more than
35 hours a week he's like oh my gosh
describe
I mean if you watch me play you are
spoiled
um
but how we started was it was a lot of
free calls because he wasn't very good
at the thing yet and so he did free
calls free YouTube breakdowns basically
pulling up somebody's Channel and do
breakdowns and that led to then some
people on the free calls would have
would call him back and say hey that was
really good how do I can I hire you
and that becomes the goal it's like you
ultimately want to be hired
but are you doing a good enough job on
the free to get people to say wow I want
I want to hire this person to come back
so it's Outreach
Zane had a great point today in
brandytics where we were pulling up
somebody's Channel we didn't know who
they were it's just like using them as
an example he's like could you reach out
to them and tell them to fix their
thumbnails and offer that as a service
like yep
yep
like if that was my business or Drew's
business you could reach out and say hey
here's what's here's what's wrong with
your channel here's what I do I'd love
to help you fix it and some people might
just talk to you for half an hour and
take your ideas and run with it cool and
some people will say wow that's awesome
how can I hire you to do that because I
don't want to do that myself
and then those people hire you you then
you do a kick-ass job helping them and
then they find more ways to work with
you and refer you off to their friends
so that's the easiest way service-based
business to get your company off the
ground is referral based marketing by
doing a kick-ass job for them
the content is the scalable way to build
the business cool so let's uh let's turn
into some questions who's got something
how can I help put your hand up and uh
let's go through lady Lexi what do you
got so when you were talking earlier
about the whole response videos I was
wondering because you do a lot of those
shorts where your team does on your
gaming channel
and I would really like to respond to
you and get into it so I noticed that on
Tick Tock you can do some stuff like a
duet or a stitch but what do you do when
it's only on on YouTube so can I post a
part of your video like a picture in
picture but what what's the norm
you need to use something it's like
these is probably Zoom
where you screen share and then have U1
as well and just adjust the size of you
like if I were to go screen share right
now you I mean we're doing Movie Makers
right I mean you see my PowerPoint
and then you see me still talking and
you can I can adjust the size of me to
be whatever
I make it small so you can see the
slides it's not like giant Evan covering
everything up but you can make it that
like ladies half the screen and whatever
you're reacting to is on the other half
that's probably the easiest way
and when it comes to title uh would I
say a response to you or would I create
a more catchy title
I would I would lead with a more catchy
title
and then
afterwards if it's not working you can
always look to split test it
okay so for example in in brand Linux
this morning we had a guy who was um
he's a copywriter for books for book
marketing
and he's already ranking at the top for
all of the like book copy marketing
keywords but nobody's searching for it
it's like it's a really small people
aren't looking book marketing copy so
he's ranking for all those but it's not
helping him drive his business forward
too much because nobody's searching for
those words
um so one of the things he does is he
does Amazon uh sales page copy so when
you write a book you need to have an
Amazon page and there's copy on the
Amazon page and we went together and
looked at the four hour work week
Amazon page and it sucked
it's got like two paragraphs there's
almost nothing on there so that could be
a good video for him of tearing apart
the four hour work week page and saying
why it sucks and how to fix it
so the video if you look at a title in
that video it should be something about
the four hour work week and how much it
sucks as opposed to my response to the
four hour work week sales page like
something that's going to catch
attention so people want to click on it
now it's ideally not just tearing it
down but then giving feedback right like
here's here's how to make it better
and of course inspired by descriptions
on YouTube
yeah that's amazing
I don't think I've ever heard anybody
say that before ever I got inspired by
YouTube descriptions okay this is great
you know that you're like obsessing over
YouTube when you lead a question with I
got inspired right into the description
so my God you're basically living inside
YouTube right now lady likes you okay I
love it I love it let's go what do you
got oh I'm living in a lumafusion right
now
it's a whole different ball game anyway
if Sam calls from self-confidence coach
and I've been looking for a while how to
call myself today I was thinking about
um
calling myself
um what was it called again inclusion
influencer because it does have the the
word inclusion in there and I actually
like to see myself as an influencer it's
way easier than coach therapist and
trainer whatever
okay so you're asking what I think about
in inclusion influencer yes it's okay I
don't know that I would I don't know
that I would lean on an influencer I
think it it's uh it still has a
22 year old
up-and-coming vibe to it as opposed to
like if you're actually an expert at it
so like inclusion expert I also saw
inclusion Creator passing by
yeah expert or Advocate or leader or
like just something with a little more
if it were me something with a little
more
uh gravitas to it if you know gravitas
uh what's uh
a little more stature to it
yeah
influencer I think people will
self-identify as influencers and they
might look for I mean if you calling if
you're looking at uh inclusion
influencer it's something that nobody's
looking for like nobody's going to
YouTube or Google anywhere and typing I
need to find an inclusion influencer
right so so now it's a branding play
like what do we want to call ourselves
is this is not for not for somebody
searching
so like if somebody's trying to find a
confidence coach then they can find Zan
and they you kind of get a sense of what
it is right like he's a coach he's going
to teach me confidence that's what I
assume it is if I go talk to him and
he's trying to sell me dog food or
something like this there's something
wrong here so but what's it what's uh
inclusion influencer like you're you're
it's not immediately understandable so
it's fine it doesn't have to be but if
you're going to then pick something
that's not immediately understandable
then let's pick something that
speaks to speaks to the you know
Prestige I guess that you're going after
so if you're going to call yourself an
inclusion leader or Advocate it just
comes off I think more powerfully than
influencer
so how to raise your rates when you
realize you are under charging your
clients and customers okay well we can
actually Workshop this what do you sell
Andrew what's what's the business
um so uh it's right up your alley my man
I so I'm a YouTube consultant I do
optimization and strategy I am
exceptionally busy I don't have a
website I don't promote I don't
advertise don't do anything it's just
Word of Mouth
and I can't keep up I've been turning
work away and just recently realized
that I'm not even charging my existing
clients what would probably be
considered the industry standard
so you're doing
are you uploading are you doing
thumbnails are you just split testing
all videos strategy all of that I
typically insert myself in the clients
organization and I coordinate all the
movement pieces I work with the graphic
designer to do the thumbnails that work
with the video editor I interpret the
data and the metrics uh
geek when it comes to this stuff I
consume everything I've I've learned a
lot about YouTube from yourself and
other and others and in fact I even have
if you haven't picked it up already it's
fantastic YouTube form a fantastic
derral Eves does it mean he just
published this thing a few months ago
right so it's it's uh the latest and
greatest with regards to YouTube and
I've been deploying what I learned there
with with my clients getting amazing
results I report I do the reporting for
my clients every every week and I have
some very very happy clients but but I'm
I'm realizing that I'm not actually
charging
um what would be considered appropriate
and so I'm like ah now I got a problem
so every new client you bring on is 30
more
and then you have a conversation with
existing clients to
increase the rate
makes sense
and you may lose some people
but if it's a good it's a good spot to
be in I mean that there may be one or
two people that you keep on just because
you love them and and they just it feels
good to work with them and help them but
they're you know they can't afford the
new rates and so you keep those on other
people uh can easily afford it and and
they have to decide what they're going
to spend it and and other people you
move on from if there's anybody you can
recommend them to great otherwise you're
you're moving on and you start targeting
more ideal clients
um
and then I went through this with
um
a couple times now with different
YouTube you know we started with Jeremy
who you know now is mid five figures
sorry mid yeah five figures mid five
figures every month
and his goal is to have 12 ideal clients
who are paying him 5K a month to help
him
yeah I don't know Jeremy but I did
recently connect with Drew and I had a
meeting with him because Zan the man
hooked us up uh introduced us so we
scheduled a meeting yeah and and so that
was eye-opening that was very very
eye-opening to see to see what how Drew
has been how he has structured his
business because it made me realize that
I need to I need to um recalibrate right
yeah well the number one thing I did
when when I helped when I invested into
Drew was start to renegotiate his
current deals it's like okay wow you're
doing way too much like this is just
you're you're you're not getting you're
giving a lot of value not getting paid
so and listen at the beginning this is
helpful for everybody at the beginning
of a coaching business
you're just figuring stuff out
you're you're happy that any client is
coming to you you're getting paid to do
what you love it's great
um I think a couple things that will
help
uh one
treat every client like it's an annual
deal not just a one-off so even Drew
turned away deals that hey can you help
me for this month like um
you can't get enough Can't Get Enough
value out of it so every now for
depending on the business maybe you can
but by default you want to think about
turning people into annual deals so you
know Terry's going to coach somebody on
how to write a book great let's turn
that into uh what does an annual deal
look like what is a book every year look
like and just default into that kind of
thinking instead of the one-offs
next is breaking down the product offer
so that when you are not just you know
you said I'll do everything for you for
YouTube great
that's a good starting point but then
you need to start breaking it down so
there's strategy strategy once a month
or every two weeks June and um Jeremy do
every two weeks because for strategy you
don't have enough for uh for every week
and if you're doing it every week you
become
uh uh more of a project manager which is
maybe what you want to do as opposed to
actually strategy
not enough happens week to week to
really justify strategy
um so if you want to be project manager
and I'm going to talk to the designer
and I'm going to get this done and I'm
going to basically as you said insert
yourself into the organization if that's
what you love doing then you have a
project management fee
you have a strategy fee
you have a
uh split testing fee yes like
optimization fee so so Drew and Jeremy
will do strategy split testing for a
certain number of thumbnails and titles
going back
um and then guidance on things like
mashup videos uh so everything that you
do is now split
and people can pick packages that they
go for with all of it or they can just
do the one thing and what that helps is
prevent scope creep to then say
oh well Andrew can you also help with
this you know and how about this and and
this too when she's already doing that
can you that happens that you're talking
my language Evan thank you yeah that has
most certainly happened that's exactly
where I'm at right now and that happens
to every Consulting business every
coaching business scope creep it's just
the I didn't know that was the term
thank you the scope of the project just
creeps forward right it's like oh and
Terry would you mind also doing this and
how about that it's like that's a whole
other offering that I that I given
listen it's not that you always say no
and you you know you bend a bit but at
some point now if this is every month
that I'm doing this it has to be part of
some kind of offering that we're putting
together
um so some of it can be organic and you
work towards but when you get enough I'm
not so worried about the beginning part
don't worry about having the perfect
plan together but as you get into it you
start to see the pattern so you know for
Jeremy for example he didn't want to do
thumbnails and split testing at the
beginning and and one of his clients
just badly needed it
because she didn't have anybody who
could do it so he said okay you know
what I'm gonna help her and I'm gonna do
it and then he realized oh you know what
it's actually not that hard and I've
gained skills to do it
great I'm going to do this for other
clients too awesome try but you have to
charge for it Jeremy that's a new
service now that's an extra 1500 bucks a
month to do split testing on your
catalog that kind of stuff so what I
would look for you is what are the how
do you how would you break it down into
the two to seven things that you're
doing consistently for clients not
nickel and diming them about
every single minute of every phone call
is being like like a lawyer would do you
know that's not what the business we
want to be in but also clients don't
know what goes on behind the scenes they
might just assume it's just easy this
one little thing for you to do right
where it's no no this is actually taking
on a life of its own and now I'm very
deep into your project
um so what are the two to seven things
that you're doing most consistently for
clients and then pricing those out as
different packages that um that you can
help with
that makes sense and in this situation
of if you are working with a client that
you enjoy working with but maybe perhaps
they're on a tighter budget does it make
sense for a YouTube expert to lower the
base fee and just ask to participate in
the YouTube ad Revenue do a red split a
web share
um
you could if you see upside you know if
you
sometimes people will do it based off of
a minimum so you know like the first
three thousand dollars a month comes to
you
and you invest in them to help them and
guide them and if you can't help them
you know if they're only making 500
bucks a month then you get the 500 bucks
but you get the first 3 000 or whatever
number you want to put in there that's
worth it for you you get the first so
you're working towards it and then
afterwards what do you
what do you want to work on
um together is that is it your stop and
you just make 3K a month is it then some
kind of share afterwards because it
turns into more of a partnership at that
point right yeah and so you have to pick
those clients extra carefully because
you're investing a ton of time at the
start to do the work and then when they
end up succeeding hopefully like when do
they even do the work to succeed because
only so much you can do is the guy
behind the scenes they have to make
videos you know they're not making
content and you can't wave a magic wand
then just help you blow up
um I do have one client that I'm
constantly like where are your videos
need your videos yes it's like do you
still want to work with them you know is
it an ideal client for you or not
um
and then working towards if I'm going to
take a piece of their Channel forever
is that is it just somebody you love
working with is it a good partner for
you
or not and as you start to build you get
a little more spoiled you can be a
little more picky you know with who you
bring on the kinds of people that you
want to work with
yeah yeah I've I've recently had some
very interesting conversations looks
like I've on boarded my first celebrity
actually so things are things are things
are going quick and I'm trying to be
smart about it and scale in an
appropriate manner so that all my
clients still receive the value that
they're used to receiving from me so
thank you very much Evan I don't want to
take up everyone's time but uh yeah
thank you and just super quick like as
you keep as you keep growing it's for
everybody too hope everybody's valuing
you know the conversation
um the kinds of clients that you want to
work with so for example Jeremy right
now on the YouTube world is only going
after pretty giant names like they're
all everybody on this Client List you
would recognize who they were and what
they're doing
um and that's what he loves doing
um Bo who I've recently invested into he
does he books he books guests for shows
so he he books he got me Matthew
McConaughey and Deepak Chopra and all
these people and then we turned that
into a service for other people so if
you have a podcast or YouTube channel
and you're looking to get some good
guests for it Beau will book the guest
for you
um which is great because that's a big
part of
writing a show is booking guests but
Beau doesn't want to work with the big
name shows Beau likes working with the
people who are on their way up not that
not the totally brand new like
I'm never going to make any money but he
he likes finding people who already have
they have a budget they've had some
success in the entrepreneur world and
they want to launch their show and they
have a budget to launch the show but
they're not people that you know of yet
and he likes
being a part of helping them grow
so it's just a totally different
clientele than what someone like Jeremy
is going after and and at the end of the
day you get the pick you know as you at
the beginning you're exploring and you
don't really know until you start
working with them so working with that
celebrity great amazing and maybe that
that's all you want to do then is work
with more celebrities or you may realize
I actually hate working with these
celebrities I'd rather work with the
level below and help them become and
that's where I get my biggest
satisfaction there's no right answer
it's more what does Andrew want to do
um and for everybody else as you start
getting into the coaching business you
get to pick because of all the things
that's the most like working with a bad
client a non-ideal fit client starts to
suck the soul out of you because it's
your actual time that you're spending
every week with them
um so those learnings of the people who
you want to start working with become
important as you build your coaching
practice thank you what do we got uh
thanks Evan for your time again for
taking our questions today and I just
wanted some feedback I just started my
YouTube channel last month so it's brand
new
um just wanted your opinion on am I
doing well or am I not
um it's called Soul aligned vision
how often are you posting uh once a week
okay so let's work to up that
okay twice a week or
as much as you can
because because part of it is just
developing the skill set of getting
getting better
okay where if you're if you're
practicing anything once a week anything
the odds of you getting really good at
it are pretty low okay so as as much as
you can
um I'd be making more videos uh I'd be
going longer like most years I'm looking
at like five six minutes yeah
10 minutes plus
okay we just talked about this inside
Movie Makers today like I'd be leaving
looking towards hour long videos if you
have enough con like you can actually
speak to it but at least 10 minutes on
it okay
um and then just just more just more
more videos more videos
like I would I wouldn't judge yourself
until you have 100 videos on the channel
okay and you've got seven which is great
hey seven first seven are the hardest to
do that's amazing but you know seven
videos listen seven videos in four weeks
that's a that's a good start
um but if you really want to start
picking up traction
I'd be I'd have Ambitions to go to one
video a day that are you know 10 minutes
plus each one
okay and and don't don't worry as much
about the editing I don't know if you
are worried about the editing or what
you're doing but
um I'm not because it was keeping me
from posting anything at all so perfect
just post next and then post again next
and then post again next
um and start to look at your data and
detraction like commend commit mentally
to making 100 videos okay or you say
it's not working or you can't make it or
it's not happening for you or whatever
100 videos in your head you'll get way
better or like you're probably already
better now compared to the first video I
am yeah and that's only seven videos in
okay but now imagine 70 videos in you're
gonna just be so much better and you'll
get your Rhythm and your flow down so uh
yeah before worrying about there's not
enough data or analytics to really pour
into yet when it's too soon
on a channel
uh because you know some of them have
done okay right like 84 views 170 views
on your mother's day one it's great
um
but yeah daily commit to 100 videos
you've done seven so you got 93 more
10 minute plus videos
and that's the start okay yeah so it
should it's okay to post seven videos
and not Market them first
um
or is it better to do three and then
Market them
so have time to Market them every other
day
Market them through what like a
newsletter send yeah send them send
people the videos you post post I post
every day and then take your best video
from the past week and then put that in
your newsletter okay
so not every video will get we'll hit
your newsletter which is fine
I do 20 to 30 videos a day
wow and not every video hits a
newsletter
okay yeah okay thanks cool good luck
lady what do you got well I recently uh
um uh created a bunch of videos or I
recorded a bunch of videos which were
all consecutive
and I was thinking about what you said
before because normally you you start
with something like an intro and get
people to get in so somewhere in between
I made a seven minute long video which
actually got into it all but I'm still
thinking can I still use the other tick
bits because I was going for a walk and
every time I saw something I just
recorded and talked about it
so it's part of a series but you want to
also talk about other things
yeah I was I was just going for a walk
it was an hour long walk so every few
minutes I I would record a few minutes
of things I thought about and and things
I saw and then when I actually was
sitting down that's when I made one
according to the structure you always
say
so later on I edited them all together
into one YouTube video and I was
thinking this isn't working so I I never
actually posted the video
well how do you know it's not working if
you haven't posted a video
um that's true
then also just post it and maybe change
the format a little bit yeah I mean and
that's the part of if you're committing
to 100 videos
great you post it it doesn't work
awesome next
okay because you got 100 to make that's
just one you got 99 more to go
you know I would play with you
walking more and maybe you discover that
when you walk like half the audio it
sucks because the wind hit the
microphone
post next and like get a better mic next
time or don't go out on a windy day or
whatever right just post and keep going
next and in in the Rhythm you'll find
what you love
and then what actually is also
resonating with the audience and then
that's what you commit to continuing to
do but in the early stages
don't say something's not working if you
haven't posted it just because
you know the vibe was off or you know
whatever reason the post
you take your hour video and you cut it
up or you just take the hour video and
you just
post it as is and then tomorrow the
other one comes up and you'll find that
in those hundred videos you'll get a few
winners
how to create a framework to teach
something ooh that's a good one I like
that we actually start that with inside
build to serve page 152 153 recipe for
success I know you guys all have the
book because you're in this group uh
there's a three-step process that that I
guide people through for you to figure
out what helped you have success that is
the thing that then you can teach other
people
so you've tried a million things right
whatever whatever hole you're in
whatever pain you came from you tried so
many things to get out I remember with
my first business I tried so many
different things so many different
things and I felt like nothing was
working like just everything I tried
just nothing was working uh and then I
discovered mall and success right then I
discovered hey Bill Gates started
Microsoft how can I model his success
and that one thing became then the thing
that I've done for the past 21 years
it's crazy 21 years so
that strategy of Mullen success is the
thing that saved me and now it's what I
teach other people it's why I make my
YouTube channel that's why I have the
you know posters on the wall here behind
me everything that I've done for the
past 20 plus years whenever I don't know
what to do model success that was what
saved me but I tried a lot of other
things that didn't work as well
so out of all the million things that
you try to get out of the hole you found
one two three things that actually
worked
that's what you have to remember you
have to go back in time to when you were
really really struggling how did you get
out of that hole and and write down the
steps right so page 153 your recipe for
Success number one is when did you
decide that something had to change so
step one to actually help people change
is realize they have to decide to change
right you can give them if we're talking
about teaching
we as teachers love teaching we love
giving the information we love giving it
knowledge we love giving the the
information we want people to change
right but if they're not if they haven't
decided to change yet then none of your
strategies are going to matter
you could tell them you know what they
need to do but they're not going to
listen to you they're not actually going
to implement if they have not decided
that they need to make that actual
change right now
uh you know Evan Ten's been in the group
I know struggled with alcohol addiction
for a long time and
he could have easily been given the
strategies he probably was given the
strategies a bunch of times by different
people he could have easily gone to
books or or articles and found hey
here's how to deal with it but he wasn't
ready yet
you know he wasn't ready at the
beginning to deal with it he hasn't
decided to change so the strategies that
you're giving don't matter yet until the
person is ready to change so go back to
your own story what was the moment that
you decided that you had to change for
me it was quitting on my business
partner right I was saying I quit I I
hate this I I need to I need to feel
like I'm a valuable human being I'm
working my face off I'm getting zero
results this can't keep going like this
that's when I decided that something had
to change so go back to your story when
did you decide that something had to
change and then you need to pull that
out of people so in your sharing of your
story you have to make it
uh be relatable which it will be right
because it's your own personal story you
have to not just gloss over it and just
tell the surface level version of it you
got to take me deep into how you were
feeling and what actually sparked the
change
and that gets people mentally prepared
to then actually listen to the teachings
right so I need this is why your story
is so important even though it's it's
scary to share uh and and you might be
worried of judgment or criticism uh if
people don't know what you went through
they're not going to listen to your
advice because they're going to say well
he well she's not like me he doesn't get
me right so you have to tell your story
and you have to go back to that point in
your story when you decided that you had
the change you were wrestling with this
for for months or years or decades or
some people
and it's this moment that you decided
that you had to change that's step one
then two was what was the first thing
you did to start to change right so
three steps right what was the first
thing you did to start the change it may
seem insignificant it may seem small it
may not seem like a big deal but what
was the first thing you did so for me it
was
I just asked myself somebody else has
had to build a software company before
and had success like who was it who was
it and and the only person I could think
of was Bill Gates and it didn't seem
like it was this groundbreaking strategy
didn't seem like this was going to be
the thing that I was going to spend the
next 21 years doing right it just didn't
seem it was that big but it actually
turned out to be and so that first step
is super important because a lot of
people if you just give the big strategy
for where they could go you tell them
where they could be in five years or ten
years or even next year they won't
believe you
they don't think it's possible they
don't think it's it's they have an
ability to get to that next big step so
what was the first little step that you
took that that in the moment felt
insignificant and small but actually
made a big difference so that gives
people hope that gives people courage
that makes me feel like it's possible so
what was the first thing you did to
start uh the change and then how did you
sustain the momentum was number three so
how did you sustain the momentum because
you you tried and stopped a bunch of
things
so how did you actually keep that thing
going what were the what were the the
strategies the tactics the habits like
what did you do to now suddenly be able
to stay consistent where in the past you
weren't
and inside of those three questions is
the framework to teach
all we want to really do is help them
get to where we are right now right you
say look at look at everything that's
possible look at where I've come you can
do this too that just don't believe that
it's possible for them
it's like to take people through that
three-step process inside those layers
and it depends on your specific story
right what worked for me is going to be
totally different than what worked for
for Krista or dwang or D or Brian or
yoonski or all you awesome people here
in the chat
but that three-step process becomes the
framework to teach
uh the next question was from Chris who
said how do you know when to keep
pushing forward and when to just move on
so the short answer is
you move on when you stop loving it
I think a lot of people
honestly even stay in businesses or stay
in relationships for too long
and they realize they stopped loving
their business a year ago or two years
ago or four years ago and they and they
kept going with it just because they
didn't want to look like a failure just
because they didn't want to tell their
family that they're closing or how their
friends would see them and they have to
start over or the humility to have to go
get a job but if you stop loving
something that's when you quit because
you're never going to win doing work
that you hate
you're just not you're never going to if
you're waking up today like oh I hate
doing if I woke up today it's like oh
inside this readers group I hate these
guys
then then it's not gonna work I'm not
gonna have the energy I'm not gonna have
the passion I'm not gonna have great
answers and it's totally gonna eat away
at me now I love you guys this is
fantastic it's the best way to start for
me uh but when you stop loving it that's
when you move on on the flip side if you
still love it and you're not getting
results then you have to keep going
because why didn't what ends up
happening is you're going to regret it
if you love doing this thing
but it's just not you know working out
yet you haven't hit the financial goals
you've got you haven't had the customer
goals you've got whatever metrics you've
set for yourself but it's not air quotes
working for you yet if you quit now
and then you go do something else
what's going to happen is you're going
to look back on this moment in three
months and six months in a year and 20
years and say I wish I kept going
because I loved it
so this is not something that anybody
can tell you to to to quit or not this
is a heart decision
so as long as you keep as long as you
still love doing the thing you might
have to find a different way to stand
it's a Oprah Winfrey quote like I had to
find a different way to stand you can't
keep doing it the way that you've been
doing it you have to find some
adjustments it's not just keep
photocopying the same thing you have
been doing because that hasn't been
working but you have to keep going and
find a different way to stand instead of
quitting because you will regret that
decision the rest of your life so Ronald
asked how to squeeze some business time
into a family day
so that's interesting especially on a
day like today which is a holiday for a
bunch of you guys here
um who are watching live
do this a couple ways one I
actually integrate my my family my wife
my son into the business uh Nina is very
familiar with what I'm doing in the
company and I used to have a really hard
time when she had a nine-to-five job
and I would be working and when she came
home she wanted to talk about she wanted
to ask me questions about my day and
what I was doing and what happened today
and
I didn't I don't have I have no need to
actually talk about what what I'm doing
you know if I have a problem I solve the
problem not by talking about it but by
trying to fix the problem and so
it was it felt frustrating for me to
try to remember what happened today for
people to share it but I realized it was
really important to her
and when the people around you
understand what's going on in your
business
and how it affects you emotionally it
doesn't become as big a Hot Topic right
so if you're trying to find an hour
today on Thanksgiving or to be here
right some people are not here because
they're celebrating Thanksgiving right
which is totally cool but you're trying
to find a 25 minute window to be here
and say I'm gonna go hang out with Evan
Carmichael instead of you guys today
right now
for them to know what this means to you
like let's just use this live as an
example for them to know what this means
to you to your business to your life to
what you're trying to create to the
community that it's helped give you
right for them to know how important
this is for you
makes a big difference compared to oh
he's just off working again
he's just stopped doing that thing right
you've blocked them out from your life
and so now they're angry at the work and
they blame the work instead of seeing it
as that integration so when they know
how important it is to you when they
know exactly what you're doing and why
and what it means to you and that just
takes an extra level of communication
it's not like you're asking for
permission right this is where people
can get blocked you're not asking for
permission to come and be on this live
or do that call or watch that video or
whatever business time is going to be
for you you're not asking for permission
you're just helping bring them into your
world
whether they can be a part of your world
and actually help you do anything right
at the beginning Nina couldn't really
help me do anything in my business she
wasn't she didn't have a role so I
didn't I didn't
I didn't see the value in just
explaining what I was doing and I did
definitely didn't want to ask her for
permission for what I was doing but
in explaining it it brought her into my
world it created more understanding and
it made things a lot easier it allowed
her to get to know me better
so if you're trying to carve out time
for work on a on a holiday or family day
the family has to feel like you're not
choosing that thing over you that
there's not this big divide between you
and that comes by from explaining and
lend them into your world right now
going a level deeper is actually trying
to involve them somehow I had a guy on
my Instagram live who's part of my
movement makers program and
he
is teaching fathers how to be better uh
how to teach fathers with daughters how
to be better fathers basically and he
wants to start this show interviewing
people and and talking about what it is
to be a father and he was trying to
carve out time for like I don't have a
lot of time because I have I have a job
until this thing takes off and I've got
I've got family responsibilities and so
I only have this amount of time you know
in the morning to be able to do this
I said well why not involve your
daughters in the show
why not have your daughters come in and
help you do the interviews when you're
when you're talking to some expert about
Parenthood why not have one of your
daughters ask a question as well
and any
took a pause and then said holy cow this
is a totally different way of seeing
things and so now it's not just okay
this is my work life and then you guys
are doing your own thing
maybe your family can be a part of what
you're doing and can be now more
emotionally involved with the work that
you're doing too and and maybe bring
even more joy and satisfaction to you
right so now he's doing he's got a I
think it was 11 and 13 year old daughter
and now they're researching who to who
to interview who they can bring on who
they can ask questions to and uh now now
his business isn't just this thing
isolated all on its own
that makes sense
uh uh okay
I found that you have to be nimble
because things change and evolved from
how you originally think is going to
happen how do you suggest shifting but
not losing the message how do you handle
your close relatives feelings on your
comments about yourself and sharing your
story that might implicate them okay so
so those are two different questions
um
let's go with the family one first
when you're sharing your story
I'm very careful not to throw anybody
under the bus
some people
obviously your family is involved in
what's happening
um some people have no problem with it
some people like no I hate that man
I don't care that the world knows that
it was him
and so they they're super happy to do it
um
I'm not in that camp you know I don't
like throwing somebody under the bus but
a lot of the story
you don't have to say who it is a lot of
the times when I'm sharing
um stories if I look at my espresso
videos where I'm going on rants or on
I'm stage speaking and I'm telling a
story about something happened to me
maybe it's Nina and and I know that
she's okay with it
uh but otherwise if it's somebody in my
family I'll often just change the
relationship or I'll change the gender
or I'll say someone close to me because
it actually doesn't really matter that
it was your father
it doesn't really matter that it was
your aunt
all that matters is it was somebody
close to you who hurt you I made you
feel this way
right so you don't have to call them out
by name and make them feel bad what
matters is your side of it without
saying that they're a terrible person or
they're a terrible human being all that
matters that you felt this way because
of what happened
and so if you have to change some of the
circumstances you have to change the
gender
um you could definitely change the name
if you're gonna even say a name
that doesn't really matter
um all that matters is how you felt
about it how you felt afterwards and
then what you did to get out of the hole
uh and then the other question was about
being Nimble be firm on the why and
flexible on the how right so the the Y
doesn't change how you do it will change
a million times
you know I want to sell the world's
biggest problem I want to help
entrepreneurs believe in themselves I
want to help the world believe
themselves but specifically
entrepreneurs I want people to wake up
and feel like today they could do
something bigger better better Bolder
than they did yesterday that you've got
Michael Jordan level genie says
something right that's what I wake up
every day trying to do how I accomplish
that's going to change a million times
you know it's why we it
built to serve we go through it right
The Who and the why are stable
they don't change once you figure out
your who your most important core value
and your why that that sets you up for
life when you're 120 years old you'll
still care about those two things but
the how how you accomplish it will
change I've had a pretty good run you
know on YouTube where it's been
11 years 11 and a half years April 2009
yeah so 11 and a half years on YouTube
we just crossed 400 million views which
is crazy
uh it's crazy
like what's the population of the U.S
it's like something like that maybe it's
more now
um
anyway it's hard to it's hard to imagine
I never thought I'd be at you know 400
million views when I when I started this
thing not at all
um but
it'll change you know in 20 years it may
not be YouTube anymore right we're going
to be hosting these all in some kind of
virtual reality room uh or VR in into
some place or holograming you know we're
all gonna meet in Evan Evan tinsman's
office you know for the next event that
it's going to change the technology will
change but
the why stays consistent so this is why
creating a perfect business plan is
never a great idea because you don't
have enough knowledge to actually know
right so many people I see spend so much
time building the perfect the perfect
business plan and then they get out the
market and start executing it and it
doesn't work
because they didn't have the perfect
information because the best way to
actually test it is to go talk to people
go start selling go start marketing go
start creating you never know which
one's going to work until you actually
start doing it but you have to get up
every day and start doing it and so
YouTube's been awesome
um you know we're playing with Tick Tock
and we're on Instagram and doing other
other forms of content I'm always going
to be doing work to help entrepreneurs
but I'm not fixed on how it happens
um in the past 24 months I was asked to
do so much speaking and and getting
bigger stages and bigger events and then
covert hits and then the speaking goes
to zero there are no events right
there's no actual events happening all
the people who are organizing events
were struggling to figure out what do we
do now this is my entire business
and so now they're doing online events
and you've probably seen a whole bunch
of them tons of different online events
summits I think even more online events
now than there were you know offline
events before covet uh and so they
adjusted I adjusted that's that's the
plan like look at what's happening right
now with covet I'm sure you've had to
make a whole bunch of adjustments
compared to your life before
but the why shouldn't change
and so it's being super stubborn on the
why
the vision that you're trying to create
and then flexible on the how of how
you're going to accomplish it forever
like it's always gonna it's always going
to be there's always going to be shock
to the system it's always gonna be the
next thing that whether it's external
like coveted whether it's something that
happens close right a family member
passes away like you'll have these
shocks to your system that
push you backwards
and you have to make an adjustment but
just keep remembering the why and being
being stubborn on it
uh crystal says how do you move past
insecurities that your content is not
good enough
so the first step is recognizing that
you're insecure that your content's not
good enough and that's actually a big
first step for most people they find
really smart reasons why they can't do
it
I can't make a YouTube video because I
don't have the camera and I I don't have
the story to share and I don't have like
all these excuses why they can't start
and and I see Zen saying the man Smith
here in the house and
be all hands up uh and Zan joined me on
my on my YouTube gaming channel so I
stream League of Legends four times a
week and answer questions as we go and
he was talking about making content
and doing Instagram lives I push him hey
you got to make an Instagram live he's
like okay yeah yeah I'll do that great
great okay like tonight like tonight I
don't even know how it works
like well
I'll show you get your phone
press this button then press that button
and boom you're going live and uh Yuko
who's also here in the chat was his
first person who joined him live
uh and it was awesome I never after that
Zane went live the next day again with
somebody else and now he knows how to do
it
we we create these so the first step to
overcome the insecurity is recognizing
that you're actually insecure because
you know in his head Zane's got all
these ideas for our August I'll do that
in January or I've got this plan for
December and when he was talking about
his YouTube plan he's like yeah I'm
gonna launch those videos next year like
next year dude next year is like 20 40.
come on let's go where's that I want
that video by tomorrow
so we have these Perfect Plans and we
have all these reasons why we can't do
things and really it's just masking and
insecurity so the the biggest first step
is just recognizing that you are
insecure about it and that's fine and
that's normal and that's human and
that's actually great because
people who are watching you don't want
to learn from the perfect person they
want to learn from somebody who is kind
of like them if you come across as
perfect all the time then to say well
that person's just perfect they don't
get me they don't understand what I what
I'm going through they're not like me so
I can't I can't learn from them so step
one recognize that you are insecure
awesome step two you then need to tell
yourself that being insecure is not a
good enough reason
to stop accepting the fear accepting the
insecurity as a good enough reason for
you not to take action
so anytime I I use it in a couple ways
so scary difficult or hard right when I
say those words it means I have to do it
or the boom boom boom test which is when
my heart's beating like this that means
I have to do it just because even if it
doesn't work out like expect it to suck
expect your first videos to suck expect
it not to go out like Zayn's first live
he's like what am I doing here this is
working uh Evan are you there you know
it's like
listen it was mine too like whatever how
does this work oh I'm live oh great wow
okay awesome yeah you don't I just
expect it to suck why do you expect it
to be great the first time out right
expect the thing to suck the problem is
we take that content sucking and we we
wear it as we suck
Zane the man doesn't suck as a human
because his first Instagram live wasn't
fantastic at the beginning right just
because it sucked it doesn't mean that
you suck
so I just expect it to suck and and as a
I flip it to say I'm amazing that I did
that I'm amazing that I tried that was
scary oh my God I'm awesome because if
you keep stepping up and doing the scary
things that you're insecure about it's
gonna get better right if if Zan makes
100 Instagram lives and we compare 100
to the first one it's going to be a
world of difference
and you can go back and watch my video
somebody posted on Instagram
uh this morning one of my first videos
and say like wow I can't believe this is
Evan like yeah you can go back and watch
go back 11 years ago and watch all the
content that was there uh there's been a
lot of growth and development and and
it's been definitely quite the journey
but
I kept all those videos up so you can
you can watch the progression and
hopefully it doesn't have to take you 11
years to get here you know as well but
just recognize that you are insecure to
except being insecure isn't a good
enough reason for you to act
um and then three just expect to suck at
the start you know to your point I think
was Crystal and I know I know we're a
time already it's crazy holy cow
um it took me 350 videos until I wasn't
completely embarrassed by my content and
I think I think I share that story and
built a survey but 350 videos 350 public
videos where I couldn't watch it back
I would play like oh stop it just post
it on YouTube and that next I could not
watch it back
um and then 700 videos before I inspired
myself where I watched my video back and
like oh you know what I'm that's
starting to get pretty good you know I
like that little video there that's
pretty I'm I'm on to something
700 videos later right I mean crazy
amounts of content
um so I I was really slow and really bad
um the only difference I just kept going
and I think I think all of you here
could probably get there way faster than
me
the problem is just allowing those
insecurities to stop you so
you do difficult things you do scary you
do difficult you do hard you're not
going to let those things slow you back
because they're going to continue to
show up if you let your insecurities win
today they're going to win tomorrow
they're going to win the next day and
win the next day as well and and what's
your message to your audience is your
message
only do something when it's perfect
you know probably not I hope not
right so but you're living it right your
message isn't only do something when
it's perfect but in your message to
yourself is I'm not going to release
until it's perfect right so you have to
start actually living and bringing the
audience in let them know I'm actually
really nervous doing this right if
that's how you feel let them in tell
them you're nervous and show them that
you still show up when you're nervous
um so super important and whether that's
writing a book making YouTube videos
Instagrams going live any of that stuff
it all all relates I know we're over but
super quick story about Yuko when she
came in she she came to my dance studio
here in Toronto and she brought these
awesome butter tarts oh my God if you
guys know what butter tarts are imagine
a pecan pie
but the size of a tart
with no pecans on it that's a that's
basically a butter type it's a Canadian
thing
um and she also made this green tea
butter types which were amazing uh and
and she was afraid to to make videos and
make content I said you know what on on
your way home she was gonna go to this
really busy train station uh Union
Station here in Toronto and I said you
have to go make a video there and find
somebody and make a video in Union
Station
um it's like oh my God I can't do that
I've barely even made any videos I'm
gonna go do that
and then but then she did it she did it
she went and she found a woman who liked
her backpack or something I forget what
the exact story was but she did it and
she filmed it and she was on and the
woman was on and and then after was like
oh my God I can't believe I just did
that it's crazy it's something I would
never do right and she did it and and
that's what you want to teach yourself
that when you come up against the fear
barrier that you do the thing right
don't do something stupid don't don't
like jump in front of a train because
that's a scary thing to do right okay
that's just a stupid thing to do but
especially when the fear is other
people's judgments of like who's
watching me with my camera here in this
busy train station it's not a good
enough reason not anymore for you not to
take action if you want to get a copy of
Bill to serve and join us live for our
next training with me to ask your
questions you can go get the book right
there next to me right there I'll see
you there I'll see you to get the book
it's a good one much love